Fabby a crucial victory for you once
again with the black pieces we were just
discussing that you've played Hans only
with the black pieces and you actually
have a score of 40 yaser aptly called it
black magic do you feel like that give
us your
perspective yeah I yeah I have a very
good score against him but I didn't feel
totally confident be before the game
today I I thought it's still going to be
a very tough game uh it's clear that
Hans moress had to win the the game to
fight for first place I don't think that
a draw would have given him many chances
and so I I really expected a tough fight
also it's after rest day so he he
definitely could prepare something so I
I was I wasn't um entirely at ease let's
say MH and the the game of course I
can't say it was a very good game I mean
I feel like uh I'm mostly benefited
because Hans was not in good shape today
and and he played probably not uh not
very well and and uh gave me chances
that I really shouldn't have had give us
your uh critical moments where do you
feel like things are murky and when did
you feel like you're finally taking over
the
initiative yeah I think the opening was
very interesting uh I played an idea
which someone played against me so I
didn't really know much about it but I
just remembered that um hin Beth played
it against me in a rapid game quite
recently this ed4 which is uh probably
was a novelty when he played it against
me I mean black can also play C6 or
something this is a very direct path and
yeah after um yeah something like C6 is
possible or queen C8 there there's
definitely a variety of moves so I
didn't know much about this ed4 but I
remembered that I didn't really get a
good position after it with the white
pieces so I decided to play it and E5
kind of surprised me I I actually
expected this queen F3 D4 Knight
E4 Queen H4 this is the yeah F6 is a bad
move yeah I had a feeling that and here
I thought uh here here I thought I could
play Queen D4 I thought I wasn't 100%
sure yes that's what we were exp Bishop
C7 more or less yeah here I I guess I'm
a tiny bit worse but more or less within
uh
equality yeah E5 I mean why why did I
play this F6 it's already it's a very
bad move after I played it I regretted
it it was kind of a lazy move um because
I was considering Queen G5 and that that
move didn't look super um promising
after Bishop C2 so I kind of um didn't
didn't look any
further sorry I'm just uh oh no worries
take your time yes this thing Queen to
G5 you spotted that but you weren't very
happy with Bishop to C2 you decided to
go F6 and then he blissed out the
sequence of moves take Tak and Knight to
H5 were you surprised by this did you
see it from afar how did you assess this
position yeah I thought that um I
thought I'm slightly worse but I thought
it's more or less um more or less okay
after F5 I mean because I'm probably
getting C5 by fource or I'm getting F4
uh so of course F4 is very logical that
he played Queen
E7 I I I didn't think that he could play
Rook C1 because Queen
B4 how does he continue here Queen D1
Queen D1 B5 can I play yes B5 okay Rook
C6 seems to Rook C uh yeah I think I
actually saw this with but I thought
something was working here but uh but I
guess not yeah then then Rook C1 of
course he K kills my counterplay um then
in in that case A3 was a mistake right
uh because after I get C5 I'm yeah it's
not so bad anymore um Rook C1 I was very
happy that he gave me C4 as well and
then he opened up things on the other
side once he started arranging his
pieces to stop your counterplay via B5
then he opened with
G5 very very aggressive uh way of
handling the position uh are you okay
with uh the
earpiece not not working out too well
today it's okay we we'll manage it's the
bane of the commentators as well I mean
Welcome to our world febby we'll get
through well you know the issue is
really not the uh earpiece it's the
glasses it's uh ah I I think it's just
one of those days you know sometimes yes
yes you get luck in one area and then it
doesn't work out in another area all
right let's discuss the last uh final
stretch of this game G5 B3 and things
get very very complicated but once you
play this move Rook to G8 we start
realizing the fact that it is your
attack that's coming first did you
realize the same thing uh over the
board yeah I I already thought that I'm
much better here and I was also uh not
sure if maybe Queen A3 instead of Rook
G8 was um I was deciding between
different options Queen a 3 yeah I
thought that maybe Queen F3 here or or
he somehow gets control of the F3 square
and then things maybe Rook F1 I I wasn't
sure but then Rook G8 okay really um
really looked very tempting I thought
Rook C3 is kind of forced uh Rook F I
thought if he plays like C5 Rook G3 I
just start crashing through yes uh and
yeah once my Rook is on G3 just attack
is Unstoppable so he has to play Rook C
or I thought he has to play Rook C3 uh I
take on C4 everything it's of course
Very concrete and then I couldn't decide
at this moment after Rook C2 which is
again forced to stop the threat of Rook
G2 uh yeah Queen H3 is of course the
first move that I considered is what I
wanted to play and then after Queen H3
Rook F2 I didn't see what I was looking
at is Rook G3 here I thought uh yeah
yeah first Rook G3 was was my intention
I mean Rook G2 I I see is but and then I
saw this suddenly this E6 Rook G8 and
queen E2 and I couldn't believe it and
then Rook E3 and queen D2
and I was like what do I do here it
looks like I should have have something
but then I realized that it's actually
very double-edged because he plays D5
ands things are getting a little bit
dangerous for you I see yeah and and
this Rook takes G2 move I thought that
The Rook end game was unclear but I was
maybe a little bit um rushy in my
decision because after Queen to D2 right
yeah I don't know why I it it was
difficult to calculate and uh yeah and
he starts pushing his pawns I don't know
if King G2 or D5 uh maybe D5 first I I
just wasn't sure and F3 I also thought
was much better for me and okay now I I
see that of course F3 is a huge blunder
um I wouldn't say a huge blunder from
from my perspective it was also kind of
the practical way out just because
you're exchanging a lot of pieces and
you're getting closer to something more
simplified yeah but it it does blow the
win I mean I once he played once I
played F3 I started to realiz that Queen
a 1 is very unclear because my first
intention after Queen A1 was to play
Queen D3 and then Queen D1 and yeah then
I realized I probably have to play a
rook in game anyway MH because I'm not
really escaping with white I was
thinking maybe Queen B3 Queen B3 here is
very interesting uh because Queen B2 I
thought and queen D5 and it's some sort
of I couldn't figure out this mess uh E6
uh yeah E6 Rook G2 Rook G2 F G2 probably
also a draw um so I thought Queen A1
would be a very decent practical chance
and uh I thought other moves were losing
after F3 so uh now I see that Rook F2 is
a draw of course uh what I I thought
after Rook F2 that I I simply take Rook
G2 Rook G2 F G2 I'm not sure if it's a
draw by the way I don't worry about this
engine the engine is not that strong
like you have Queen D2 but it's uh it's
stronger than me
Christian probably yes no I I just
thought this was winning I I didn't see
Queen d 2 Queen H3 Queen G5 uh like I
didn't see this that the square is both
defending and and threatening the
Perpetual okay the good news is I always
have a draw like Rook G8 he has to force
a draw but um but to win this is
probably like I probably would play Rook
G8 at this moment I I don't think I
would get get the uh get the courage to
play Queen G4 here uh so yeah but of
course E6 is shocking no matter what he
chooses maybe Rook F2 maybe Queen A1 but
E6 is just resigned I didn't understand
his idea I guess it was just like Panic
or something because this of course I
can probably win this in a variety of
ways because he actually doesn't have
threats here I mean E7 is always met
with Rook E8 so I thought yeah maybe I
have other ways to win maybe Rook E8
maybe some H pawn move but I guess what
I did was also pretty um clearcut yeah
well an important victory for you you're
eliminating one of the contenders but
you still have a couple of them behind
you lener is one of them he just won his
game and Wes seems to be primed to win
his game as well how do you see the last
couple of rounds playing
out I still think it'll be very tough I
yeah there some players are starting to
get some momentum uh I'm actually
surprised that Wesley is is winning I I
thought his position was pretty
dangerous looking but of course it was
so double-edged that anything could
happen uh but that's that's an important
win for him lenier I did have a feeling
that he he would be a heavy favorite to
win today because um Andrew is a good
player but he doesn't have good openings
and lenier is one of the best prepared
players so it's uh it's very difficult
uh to get a good position against him so
yeah I I'm not too surprised that some
people are starting to try to catch up
and also I play Wesley in the last round
with black I play Misha who is also
doing very well tomorrow so it's uh yeah
I don't imagine it will be an easy
finish definitely a Tense one to be
followed guys any questions our
congratulations and I actually do have a
question uh Fabi uh I know I know we had
a rest day yesterday but still it's been
nine rounds already how are your energy
levels going to the last two
rounds uh more or less okay a little bit
a little bit more tired than I I was at
the start of course but uh and it yeah
it is like nine rounds is usually a full
tournament so it's it's quite a long
event but compared to um let's say some
other events it's it's relatively
relatively relaxed schedule let's say
the candidates or uh or the World Cup
these events really are much more
draining so I think everyone's getting a
bit tired but but probably not overly so
and we do we do have two rest days in
this event so also some some time to
rest and um yeah I would say not too
tired at the moment okay that's good
good luck in the rest of your tournament